at that point I'd never kissed a woman
before and so I was like oh that could
be interesting Rebel Wilson gets
personal about how she started dating
her partner Ramona agruma in an
interview with today's Maria Shriver the
actress reveals how her new movie the
almond and the seahorse opened her heart
to finding love with a woman well I have
an affair with french actor Charlotte
gainsberg in it yeah do not be nice to
me I wouldn't dream of that
[Music]
future we're not present they never
kissed a woman before and then it kind
of led to this kind of Discovery and
which led to my awesome partner Ramona
and I I don't know whether that would
have happened if I you know I might not
have been open to that if I hadn't have
done the emotional work and then the
movie that it was kind of like a little
crack opening to that possibility Rebel
went public with her relationship with
Ramona a fashion designer back in June
after an Australian news Outlet
attempted to out them as a couple
instead Rebel broke the news herself on
Instagram with this pic captioning it I
thought I was searching for a Disney
prince but maybe what I really needed
all this time was a Disney princess
hashtag Love Is Love it's like love is
in the air at the time source told E.T
quote they are very happy together for
me there was something about turning 40
that I just was like okay I feel like
I'm stepping into my own power in 2020 I
did my year of health where I like tried
to transform and become like a healthy
inversion of myself through that I did a
lot of like emotional work yeah
I'm good them concentrating on health
yeah Rebels made a few life shifts
recently including A Renewed commitment
to her health which opened the door to
Motherhood I was like oh I really do
want to become a mother but at the time
I didn't have a partner and so I went to
the fertility doctor
and he kind of looks me up and down and
says oh well you'd have a much better
chance if you were healthier I was so
angry at first and then I was like oh
hang on like I am putting a lot of
things into my body and a lot of toxins
that I don't need at first it wasn't
even really myself it was more thinking
of a future mini me really after losing
80 pounds Rebel started the IVF process
and being healthy and done everything
the doctors had said and you know
feeling awesome and then it didn't work
I was still young enough to try it a few
more times and then luckily got my
gorgeous baby girl last month she
welcomed daughter Royce Lillian via
surrogate oh you hold the baby and cut
the umbilical cord and literally from
from that moment you're just like it was
just like amazing and so emotional but
it's really challenging well now how do
I do all the things and and be a great
mother and great partner and all of that
and earlier this year while chatting
with E.T Rev shared her definition of
living her best life
my best self is like definitely someone
who's living a healthy lifestyle
um which is both like physically and
mentally and so I'm always kind of
working to to improve things
[Music]